good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through grants from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations on
Fridays from leading thinkers about the
issues promised opportunities and
hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covet
19. these include but do are not limited
to delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health concerns drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle
is now open and we welcome Junior
faculty members who are working in areas
such as infectious diseases epidemiology
clinical medicine population Health
Data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe that this
will be an exciting opportunity and
engaging program where characterizing
the secondary effects of covid-19
necessitates unique multi-disciplinary
approaches to understanding these
secondary health consequences
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab will
Leverage The presentations you're just
about to hear as well as vital material
for our upcoming culminating and person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June 2023. today I
am delighted to welcome our speaker
Professor Shane G Henderson from Cornell
University Dr Henderson holds
uh the Charles W Lake Junior chair in
productivity in the school of operations
research and information engineering at
Cornell University he earned his
bachelor's degree in mathematics from
the University of Auckland in 1992 his
master's degree in statistics from
Stanford where he also received his PhD
in operations research in 1997. his
research interests include discrete
event stimuli simulation simulation
optimization emergency service planning
and transportation he's the
editor-in-chief of the Open Access
Journal stochastic systems he is an
informs fellow and a co-recipient of the
informs Wagner prize for his work on
bike sharing programs so in continuing
with our biomedical data science
Innovation or excuse me biomedical data
science seminar series theme Shane's
lecture today is entitled keeping campus
open designing mitigation strategies
with biased data unlike most
universities Cornell was very
um adventurous in reopening its Ithaca
campus for in-person instruction in the
fall of 2020 during the covet period and
did so safely through the use of pooled
testing their decision to do so and many
others were Guided by the mathematical
modeling group and Shane will discuss
some of the questions they explored the
models they built and data that informed
their models and how they dealt with
several interesting challenges Cornell's
work here under the direction of Shane
and his colleagues helped him motivate
um further work in exploiting biased
data in epidemiological models as always
we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you for
joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they may have for Shane in the chat
feature of their Zoom sessions all
synthesize these and ask those questions
on your behalf in the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome
Shane we are so much looking forward to
your lecture
you're mutaging
yes I am indeed thank you Jack it's
great to be here uh and I really
appreciate the opportunity to to tell
you a little bit about our experience so
yeah I want to tell you about the
Cornell experience which is not unique
but it's close to Unique
um I want to introduce a few characters
here first so Peter Frazier the person
on the left he was the ringleader so he
was he was the guy who really brought
this all together he's a faculty member
in this department with me uh David
schmoy is beside him is another faculty
member in the department who led another
Direction in this work and I'll explain
what what he was doing there and then we
had this sort of large cast of
characters to the right it's a mix of
PhD Masters and undergraduate students
and then there'll be some more people
with the obligatory Zoom window shot a
little bit later in the talk but these
were the main characters so what we were
doing was trying to ensure that we could
keep the Cornell campus open uh in by
hook or by crook but using some sort of
Philly a powerful methods to keep things
under control but our story was not
uniformly positive and I want to bring
out those those aspects as well
so
uh the key themes that we're going to
bring out that we're going to see in
this talk uh number one Cornell reopened
safely in the fall of 2020 so as you'll
recall that was the the sort of the the
semester immediately after The Madness
of March April May uh period
Cornell has remained safe uh to to the
present time but we've had our share of
uh sort of interesting moments
uh the the word modeling here refers to
mathematical modeling so uh lots of
mathematical epidemiology in here uh but
our group we're not really
epidemiologists uh directly but we do
have a lot of experience with operations
so you heard about the bike sharing work
earlier that uh is certainly doesn't
look anything like this work but the
mathematical principles are kind of
similar
so we looked at things like uh testing
the testing frequencies how often we
actually test individuals to try to keep
people safe we looked at classroom
safety is is it safe to bring people
into the classroom if they're socially
distanced wearing masks we looked at
should the university require boosters
you know a whole bunch of uh different
questions and it was a incredible
experience where we were directly linked
with the leadership of the University
and the reason this was possible was
that we have science driven leaders here
at Cornell uh president Martha Pollock
is a computer scientist our uh Provost
Mike kotlikoff is something that I
cannot pronounce but it's a science kind
of position anyway
um so then we have uh many other aspects
to this work that made this work so huge
efforts in communication you'll see a
couple of examples of that later on but
a big one for example was that Peter the
person I mentioned to you first who was
our leader was meeting daily with the
other leaders of the University uh
Martha Mike and and others daily through
that fall 2020 semester to try to make
sure that things were going okay and so
that that sort of gives you an idea of
the the penetration to the leadership of
the University
our modeling group had an appreciation
for and explicitly modeled things that
we didn't know and this will be a theme
that we'll bring out later
and I think it's important to recognize
both the strengths and the limitations
of the data that we had available I will
try to highlight that as well
a key point is that we did the analysis
when it was needed and that meant that
we didn't do the perfect analysis we did
something that enabled a decision to be
well informed and that meant sometimes
that we couldn't do the analysis we
really wanted just because of time
pressure
and then a final theme is that in in
doing all of this we actually used a
range of different decision models not
just one and the models were sort of
complementary to one another that theme
won't come out too uh explicitly in this
talk but it's it's certainly underlay
much of what we did
so I want to uh take you back to this
period so March 2020 through to December
2020 in this first part of this
conversation and the picture you're
seeing here is of the lovely Ithaca
Campus of Cornell so that we also have
other campuses there's Cornell Tech in
New York City but this is the one in
Upstate New York
so
uh the question we were facing back in
June of 2020 actually a bit earlier than
that was should we ask students to
return in the fall just like all other
universities were considering and this
was done in the context of some rather
disturbing case counts uh you're seeing
a sort of a blurry image here I
apologize for the quality of something
like what we were seeing in case Council
written around that time and this was
the context in which we were trying to
make this decision
and there were two different
perspectives on this left and right of
this uh panel respectively on the left
there was this perspective that bringing
students back was dangerous they they
would be irresponsible they would have
parties like you see in this upper left
and that would lead to a number of
people
um being infected when they would not
otherwise have been and so it was
perceived as a dangerous consideration
but trade that with the right hand side
perspective which is that when people
are purely online
they are isolated and that can lead to
all kinds of problems educational
problems mental health problems and so
on but also for a town like Ithaca which
is quite small there are a number of
Staff would have lost their jobs because
they would we would they would not have
been supporting students who were there
alive so these are serious issues uh
it's lives it's also livelihoods
so uh the issue here that we wanted to
exploit was testing and certainly
testing was a hot hot button issue back
then the thing that made us uh have hope
was that we were fortunate in that we
have a Veterinary uh hospital here on
campus and our lucky break we have a PCR
lab for testing livestock and it was
believed that we would be able over the
summer to modify that lab to enable it
to do PCR testing for our students and
staff faculty community
so like many places we started to
explore poured testing so just as a
quick recap you take a bunch of swabs
from individuals into their individual
tubes but then what you do is you take a
bit of the fluid from each of those
first those five cubes
do one test to see if virus is present
in the pooled sample if the test comes
back negative we conclude perhaps
incorrectly but we conclude that all
five samples are negative if it comes
back positive then we'll test the
original tubes individually to try to
hunt for the individuals that are
positive so we use pool testing with
pools of size five in the lab and with
this kind of two-stage approach
so the strategy that was proposed back
in April of 2020 was
should we test all well we'll test all
students upon arrival to the campus and
then every on a regular basis after that
we will contact Trace isolate the
positives we will use aggressive
quarantining and what we call adaptive
testing adaptive testing is where let's
say that somebody tests positive on the
hockey team then rather than wait for
that person to identify the other
members of the hockey team as being
potential contacts we would just
quarantine the entire hockey team until
they could be tested and determined
positive or negative
and then we of like every other place
we're considering masks and social
distancing but we also and this was
David schmoise the second person I
highlighted uh contribution or key
contribution was we rebuilt our class
schedule so I'll tell you a bit about
that as well
the big question was
can this work
will we be able to bring people back
safely
so we used a pretty standard approach so
we built a sort of a simulation model
this is a standard seir kind of model
with a few extra compartments
um so I won't go through the details
here I'm sure you've seen these things
many times but basically just tracking
People's State in the population and we
included some additional information
which would be standard information for
these as well I just want to highlight
the groups so we had students who were
we we separated the population into
groups and uh an important group there
was undergraduates who were in high
density housing staff and faculty with
frequent student contact and there were
other groups as well but I'll just sort
of mention those for now
and then we just use this model as a as
a predictor and you can see the sort of
standard curves that you tend to see
from these seir models
one thing you'll notice is that these
curves are a little bit Wiggly that's
because we have a stochastic simulation
model our model is not a differential
equation model at least this one is not
what we've built here is a is is
actually modeling uh the randomness in
in the sort of daily fluctuations we
felt that was important because the
number of infections we were aiming for
was quite small and when the number of
infections is small those differential
equation models are not as helpful as
they might otherwise be
so the key issue of course was
populating this model with parameters
that we actually believed and so what
are those parameters that things like
the probability that someone gets
infected when they have a close contact
it's the probability of having severe
disease given that you've been infected
and all of these parameters are
stratified by age groups because as you
can imagine or as you know the campus
population has a heavy block of these
young adults who are the students but
then also has a distributed population
through the staff and faculty
so we were hunting for data in those
early days so imagine it's April or May
of 2020 we were trying to figure out
what these parameters ought to be so you
probably remember the Diamond Princess
cruise ship and there was early data
coming out of uh Wuhan uh Washington
State and also Italy
so we would uh what we did is we we
looked at those we looked at all other
kinds of sources it's certainly the CDC
website but then what we had to do was
try to sort of reconcile all of these
conflicting data sources to try to
predict what kind of disease spread
parameters and so forth we would we
would be experiencing so we used various
fitting methods to to try to come up
with numbers that made sense and for
example we we had some conflicting data
from Washington State and from some of
these cruise ships and what we did was
we said well let's find the most likely
value of these parameters
but subject to constraints on things
that we believe are true such as the
probability of severe disease-given
infection
is increasing in age
right so that given that you've been
infected you're probably of severe
infection should be increasing as you
get older and so we would we would use
those kinds of constraints to
um if in effect sort of improve the
ability of the data to inform these
models
all of the data was biased that's for
sure because the data came from
different uh different
um scenarios or different worlds from
from the campus so uncertainty
quantification in our world was
essential and what I mean by uncertainty
quantification is not pick the most
likely value of these parameters and
then run with that it was there are a
range of these input parameters that
could be important let's make sure that
we've got some coverage of that
uncertainty that we're representing our
uncertainty in some reasonable way
but after all of that the simulation
model suggested to us that testing could
really have tremendous impact so uh in
this picture what you're seeing on the
horizontal axis is a prediction of the
percentage of the of the campus
population that would be infected over
the course of an entire semester
and on the vertical axis you're just
seeing how often that happens in our
simulations
so for the Cornell Ithaca campus if we
do not do surveillance testing our
models were predicting that we would see
something like 60 of the population
infected over the course of the semester
and the reason it's sort of bunched
around 60 is because you're reaching
some kind of herd immunity up at that
level
uh but if we were to do the surveillance
testing with a frequency of once every
five days which is not that convenient
but um in any case suppose that with the
frequency then you would see this
bunching down near zero so still
positive but but down near zero and it
was plots like this that immediately
gave us confidence that we were onto
something here
so the key thing though was then well
how can we make this as effective as
possible given the capacities that we
have for testing so I want to show you a
plot and on this plot you can see daily
tests on the horizontal axis and
infections on the vertical so I'm going
to take a particular method for testing
so here the letter B corresponding to
this point means that we're going to
test undergraduates who are in high
density housing twice a week
we will test off-campus stuff once a
month and everyone else once a week so
that's one strategy one could follow
there are other strategies but if we
follow that strategy we would need
something like
4 000 tests a day
and we would need uh sorry we would
experience we predict something on the
order of 2000 infections over the course
of the semester
so that's the prediction for one testing
regime and we looked at a whole bunch
and so we generated a plot that looks
like this
uh so uh each of these uh letters here
again corresponds to a different testing
regime and the one we selected is this
one that's sort of highlighted here
so one thing that was critical uh or
sorry one thing I want to emphasize
before the administration saw this plot
they were planning on 4500 tests a day
as being the maximum capacity they could
support
after seeing this plot they bumped that
up to 7 500. so this plot had an
enormous impact on the University's uh
intended
strategy for dealing with testing and
the reason that they wanted to go to the
higher level and perhaps put on the
extra shifts that are needed for that
was that they could see that this was
providing some level of robustness by
moving to 7 500 tests a day we could be
we were sort of a long ways away from
this kind of scary uh jump here
so we worried endlessly about
uncertainty so in this plot you're
seeing
um uh the average number of contacts per
person per day
that's uh sort of just um an important
measure in all of these these models and
and the nominal value the value that we
felt was sort of most likely for this
parameter was something somewhere around
about eight slightly over eight so about
here because that's a log log plot
um that would lead uh in our sort of uh
sort of middle or sort of expected
scenario to a certain percentage of the
population being infected which here
looks like it's about four so if if if
the truth is eight contacts per day
we'll see about four percent of the
population infected but this quickly
changes as that average number of
contacts per day increases or decreases
so we had many plots like this exploring
the potential for problems
uh and this plot was another one that
was very influential on the
administration so on the horizontal axis
I'm showing you the expected number of
contacts per day we can't control that
that is something that we just have to
live with and we don't know where it's
going to fall on this axis
on the vertical axis I'm plotting the
daily percentage of the population that
we test and that's something we can
control
so we have something we can control on
the vertical but something we cannot on
the horizontal
and what we're what you're seeing in
this plot this is a contour plot that
shows the expected number of infections
you would see through combinations of
these two parameters so if we have 15
contacts per day a very high number but
we're testing a third of the population
per day
then we would expect to see something
like 1500 invitations and you can see a
kind of a cliff here in this Contour
plot this region here is really scary in
any case the nominal value for this
expected number of contacts per day was
eight but we had some uncertainty about
where that was going to fall
if we test once every five days then we
expect to see something like uh uh what
is this about 1500 infections but notice
how close we are to this Cliff if that
number of contacts is slightly higher we
could be in serious trouble
so by elevating
the number of tests per person the
frequency of testing we can we can move
up on this curve reduce the number of
expected infections but also move
ourselves away from this Cliff so that
was vital
and then this uh con the conclusion one
obtains from this plot is that the the
big one this is the the one that really
swayed the administration this was the
the sort of Crux so what are we seeing
in this plot I want you to notice that
you've got residential Cornell
infections listed down here so that says
if we hold a regular residential
semester
how many infections might we see in a
particular situation and then on the
vertical axis I'm showing you a
different uh prediction this is virtual
coronal infections that means if we go
online only
so no in-person classes at all
then how many infections might we see in
our in our population
each dot in here
is a prediction from the simulation
under a plausible set of input
parameters so remember all those
parameters we didn't know what they were
each dot here corresponds to a plausible
value for those parameters and then what
you're seeing is this cluster of dots up
here so what's going on like pick this
dot here just this one
so what we're assuming here or what
sorry what we're predicting is that if
the true parameters are corresponding to
this dot then we would probably see
whatever this number is down here uh
residential Cornell infections
um in a residential semester
but if we were instead with the same
parameters running a virtual semester
then we would see something like
whatever this is maybe 600 or something
um so
each of these dots then corresponds to a
particular possibility of the world and
you notice that all of the dots pretty
much are above the line so that's
telling us that we will typically expect
to see many more infections if we go
virtual than if we go residential there
are a few places where the dots fall
below the line down here but in those
situations the number of infections is
quite modest and so there we are not
focused on those from risk what we care
about is this big area up here
now in some scenarios it's bad no matter
what you do so these kinds of scenarios
up here this is just the situation is
just too dire you can't keep up
so a plot like this was incredibly
important because it's sort of telling
you that basically you should go
residential and that sounds a little bit
weird right like you're bringing people
back for in-person semester and you're
gonna uh be in better shape that way
well the reason this was this was good
was that
uh
when people come back for a residential
semester we can enforce a behavioral
compact which says you will be tested on
a regular basis
you come back to the campus you sign up
for residential you will subscribe to
this but for the virtual uh semester
there's no such mandate we can impose
not legally and uh we knew from surveys
that we were going to get many people
coming back to the campus anyway that
already paid for their lease and so they
the students would want to come back
so in that virtual semester we have a
large campus population who are sort of
in the general area but they're not
getting tested frequently and therefore
if there is infection it's going to
spread through that population very
quickly so these dots all correspond to
infections sort of getting out of
control
and getting an epidemic amongst that
um that on-campus Community
um so that was the key and and when
Martha Pollock our president saw this uh
um she didn't see this exact plot but
when she saw this conclusion
um the decision was very clear for her
she wanted to minimize harm and the
right way to do that is to have the
residential semester
so uh she and Mike kotlikov wrote an
article for the Wall Street Journal
which was explaining the the planning
here and uh so this article was put out
there to to basically win hearts and
minds and explain what the decision was
you'll notice here that there's a
a little phrase here it says
surprisingly the work that we've done
um you know sort of explains what's
going on
so uh again you're seeing this theme of
communication
uh there was more communication so Peter
uh appeared before the faculty Senate uh
he appeared on ABC News along with the
leaders in the University uh here's
Peter again I guess on The Daily uh
newspaper we were also interacting with
local politicians to to help make
decisions for the local uh sort of the
broader Community because at Cornell is
a in an Upstate area you're not making
decisions in isolation you have to think
about the the surrounding Community as
well but basically what was safer for
Cornell was also safer for the community
so that was the analysis that was
leading up to the big decisions in the
summer uh to to reopen but there was a
little bit more to the story I'm just
going to highlight some of that and then
highlight what happened when we when we
reopened so uh the the key question here
was well we're going to go residential
but uh we also don't want people just
sitting in their dorm rooms can we run
classes in some sort of safe manner
and
it was clear that the the very big
classes you know imagine psych 101 or
something or calculus those classes had
to go online only because they were just
too big that we couldn't put them
anywhere but for the smaller classes
what we could do is we could use the
large rooms on campus and spread those
students out in those classrooms so we
we planned that so we would have them
six feet apart and we would
um uh sort of rotate them through
eligibility for attending in-person
classes so I'll skip this about pod
models so
um the the natural thing that you can
see is that the classroom capacity is
going to be a small fraction of what you
can normally use so we have to realign
and recreate this class schedule so
David schmoise and his team uh this gang
rebuilt that classroom schedule over the
the summer of 2020. and there was a lot
to that story so uh they had many many
hair racing moments I'm just going to
sort of skip through some of this but
basically it was six weeks from when
they started to do that to when they had
a had a schedule the the issue that they
were really frustrated with was that
they had to integrate with the existing
computer systems on campus and some of
those computer systems are pretty old so
there were some real challenges there uh
one key thing that I want to highlight
here is they had they had different sub
teams that were building two different
ways to do the scheduling they had the
method that they really wanted which is
this thing they're calling the
decomposition approach but they had a
separate approach which was just based
on some sort of reasonable heuristics so
that if the decomposition approach were
to fail they would have this heuristic
to fall back upon
and um so the the biggest hurdle for
them was was dealing with the computer
systems and they came down to the wire
and David is fond of telling us the
story of when Mike kotlikoff our Provost
fixed him with a Steely uh stare and
said you will have a schedule for us by
tomorrow won't you David and David said
yes sir and then he had to go and figure
out how to do it but they got it they
got it
so it worked and I want to just uh show
you uh uh one statistic for that so here
you're seeing a plot of student
enrollment on the horizontal axis and
total infections over the the Academic
Year not just the fall for a bunch of
different universities
so each dot here corresponds to a
different University and then the color
coding tells you uh what their status
was so the thing you notice is that
Cornell is sitting here it's a campus of
about 21 22 000. uh students
the outcomes we had with our hybrid year
were quite similar to Harvard's which
was fully online
um and Harvard
um
uh was sorry so Harvard was fully online
so these are fairly similar
um you notice that Chicago down here
um with a with a smaller enrollment
header similar number of infections but
basically the experience here was
similar
um and then these these online only uh
colleges uh head
um you know maybe not such a good
experience yeah sorry Stanford did
pretty well but uh but they were online
only MIT and Yale had had more concerns
now to be fair some of these
universities are more
um Urban campuses where there's a lot of
interaction with the surrounding
community and we had less of that so we
were able to get away with that I think
but essentially we had a good year
some places that were facing the same
decision and went with online only had
the opposite experience so Michigan
State University this is near Lansing in
Michigan uh they they are sort of
similar in that it's a sort of a more
rural kind of area they went online only
and they had this big surge of cases at
the start of the semester and so they
they were forced to uh to try to get
people away from the town so this was
the thing we were worried about
so we did not experience that surge
so there were hiccups here all the way
through uh students
um were we discovered that students had
new quarantine rules just a few days
before uh the students were due to
arrive so these were imposed by New York
State
um also from New York state from
Governor Cuomo all of a sudden there was
a new rule about a week and a half to
two weeks before the semester began
saying if an educational institution has
a hundred cases or more in two weeks
they must go online only
and what annoyed us was that this number
100 was a constant threshold it didn't
matter the size of the institution so
Cornell was subject to the same cap as
Colombia as NYU as all these other
universities including some very small
ones so that was annoying but it turns
out we were okay with that uh one thing
that happened that was a bit of a scare
was after November 3rd of 2020 and
that's a significant date
um from the political side we had an
outbreak but you know what are you going
to do and then also uh you know we had
our own sort of problems as well and I'm
sure you did too uh turns out mbas and
St Patrick's Day uh not not great
so each semester had new problems new
challenges so the spring of 2021 you may
recall the UK variant was uh on the on
the horizon we were concerned about that
showing in showing up and that would
mean that the estimates that we had for
infection rates and so forth for the
fall just gone were too low so we had to
deal with that uh we weren't sure what
fraction of the the student body would
be vaccinated and and then as the summer
of 2021 sort of progressed we were
learning more about Delta and embracing
ourselves for that and changing our
interventions
but I want to now move to a really
tumultuous period and just sort of
really highlight the the impact of
real-time data because up till now what
I've shown you is the impact of modeling
uh and now what I want to say is or what
I want to highlight is is yes there was
modeling but there was also just looking
at the data and looking at it in
creative ways
so this was our experience throughout
the period that we've talked about till
now so in the fall of 2020 we had some
scary moments this was when the semester
was beginning and what happened was our
testing had not yet begun and there were
a student's partying not many but some
and that created this kind of surge in
cases here
then we had a quiet fall semester which
was great
um until November the 3rd
um here and then uh quiet period through
uh but then we had
um problems with parties and spring
break and
um the Saint Patrick's Day and so on in
this period but we got through uh not
much happening in the summer
and then when people came back and Delta
was present as well
um most we had a vaccination requirement
everybody was vaccinated or basically
everybody was vaccinated
um but you can see this this huge Spike
so this was Delta
and uh we weren't sure we were going to
get on top of it but we did manage to
get on top of it and then control the
rest of the semester but what I want to
show you now is what happens subsequent
to what you're seeing in this plot
so the Story begins on uh Wednesday
November 24th the day before
Thanksgiving so we expected a spike in
cases as students return from their
homes bringing covert back with them
we'd seen that many times before
and on that day Omicron was was
uncovered and so became something that
that could potentially be concerning
on Thanksgiving it was classified as a
variant of concern
and on that day Gary karetsky this is
this person you see up here Gary was
what is one of the leaders of the campus
he sent an email to the Provost and
Peter saying hmm should we be worried
about this
um so uh we all had our Thanksgiving
turkey or whatever and then we gave
ourselves a day off after that and then
on November the 27th we started thinking
well we better plan for Omicron it's
probably going to be here in the spring
we're going to have to be alert to that
so we're going to use the remaining time
in the semester to Think Through how we
can address that so we realized that the
testing schedules that we were using
even with the fully vaccinated
population we're not going to be enough
that was uh that came out from our
modeling pretty quickly so we needed a
new strategy
so
um a little bit later we had gone
through that period after the
Thanksgiving period where we thought we
had controlled the cases and um and sort
of handled the surge it was actually not
much of a search there
so um we say okay there was a bit of a
surge but it's okay it's not too bad and
that's just the Thanksgiving break and
people having parties when they get back
and end of classes it'll be okay
so on December 8th things took a turn
for the worse and we discovered that
there had been this big we call them
guardless big parties to celebrate the
end of classes and we started looking at
these numbers with some trepidation the
numbers seem to be increasing classes
had stopped and we were in study week
um the the case counts remained elevated
on December 9th and we were worried and
then we got really worried because it
just wasn't showing any sign of ticking
back down despite the the testing that
we were doing
so we started to question whether this
is Omicron and on Saturday it was uh
really scary so I was planning an exam
in my class a big class
um the following day
and I was hearing from students quite
frequently that they had tested positive
and were isolating and would need some
sort of accommodation and it got to the
point where I thought this is beyond
what I can handle uh in any kind of
reasonable way so I canceled my class uh
my exam and came up with some other plan
uh but this was really just getting
moving and
um
on that day we said to the
administration maybe this is Omicron
right like like we're seeing huge case
counts and we're not controlling it it's
different from what we've seen in the
past
and
on that day
we had to make a big decisions or we
wanted to we needed to explore a
decision so the lab had been checking
um throughout uh for testing you know
just testing students but they weren't
necessarily just testing for Omicron
they didn't have the time to do the
additional work that was needed to to
determine whether a positive case was
Omicron or Delta
and so we had seen a couple of Omicron
samples very early in December but we
the the thinking was that we had
controlled for that it it was okay but
because the lab was just so overwhelmed
with these case counts you know here 200
in one day they were not able to do this
additional testing that was needed to
look for Omicron markers
so the question was should the lab pause
its testing of uh cases in general
because it takes time to do this to look
for Omicron in the the positive samples
that would allow us to change the way
that the university is operating because
we would then have the clear sense that
atomicron
but it would it would slow down
um finding infectious people and
isolating them so we could that could
actually that decision to look for
Omicron could lead to more cases overall
so there was some disagreement amongst
the leadership group uh about whether
Omicron had arrived
on the I believe it was the next day
um so uh we showed the administration
this plot so on the horizontal axis is
time and on the vertical axis cases the
gray area here is the people that have
been identified in contact tracing and
the red region here is the fraction of
those uh potential contacts
uh the fraction of those contacts sorry
who tested positive
and what you see is this kind of giant
um shading of red here and if you look
at the fraction of the gray that's
covered by red this is a very scary area
because it's showing that a very large
fraction of the contact tracing
individuals uh are testing positive so
we're seeing a much larger fraction of
people testing positive and that uh was
a very strong signal it seems to drop a
little bit later but that's just because
certain numbers hadn't been reported by
the date that we obtained this data
so we took this data to the
administration and
yes we say it's Omicron
um
uh I guess I'm getting a little ahead of
myself but but uh Peter Frazier and I
went to a conference that we typically
go to
um that evening Peter had a call with
the Provost and other leaders
you know should we be pausing that lab
given the information we're seeing in
this plot you see in the top left and
the decision came from Mike yes we we
need to do that so on Monday December
13th they tested many of the uh samples
and what they found was that yes there
was sgn Dropout in a large very large
fraction basically overwhelming now
that's not proof that it's Omicron but
it's pretty strong evidence and that was
enough to say yes we need to change the
the strategy of the University
so on December 14th uh we went uh we had
to go we were forced to go to this
online only kind of uh strategy for the
exams that were left
um we you know we put in a whole bunch
of other restrictions
um and uh then yes sure enough we showed
up on CNN uh because this was the first
real instance the first uh outbreak that
we had seen in the US
uh Peter tried to to live under his
normal life give us give his conference
talk and then immediately after that he
started talking to reporters
um I always had this sort of delightful
position that I was embedded deeply
within the modeling team but Peter was
the figurehead and so Peter was the the
guy that sort of carried the the bulk of
this
so what happened overall well this is
the amazing thing Omicron arrived on
campus four days after it was it was uh
discovered four days and we were hoping
for spring semester but it was just
shortly after this thing was discovered
there's no way our testing regimes were
able to keep up with its transmissivity
and so we had a large number of
infections 2 800. almost entirely
actually undergraduates but there were
some graduate students as well
no hospitalizations so uh consistent
with other things you will have heard
about Omicron
and the big thing that I want to
highlight is that this focus on
real-time data really did change the way
that Cornell responded to the situation
so then we had to sort of say well now
that we've sort of somehow managed to
hobble through to the finish line on the
fall semester what do we do next so our
data suggested from contact tracing data
that Omicron was three to five times
more transmissible than Delta
um
so students are kind of done with them
asking you know they were kind of fed up
at that point we all were right and so
we just concluded that very large
student infection counts were just going
to be part of the deal for the spring
and so we had models that that we're
looking at if we test once a week twice
a week and so on and you see that these
curves are bending down but the
infection counts are very large here so
we were concerned that there wasn't much
we could do
so the good news is that the as as we've
seen the serious health effects are
unlikely most of the cases are mild but
I do recognize that this group is is
sort of expert in Long covered it's an
area I know nothing about so that was
something that we did not factor into
our calculations
so another thing that we had seen and
this I also want to highlight infected
students almost never infect uh
non-student employees that staff and
faculty
um so
um we didn't see that kind of
transmission moving uh into the staff
and faculty which meant that the
infections tended to be confined to them
for the most part amongst the younger
population
so
um we were now operating in a new world
where the case counts were going to be
large and as I said earlier
um we were previously our models were
sort of previously designed to be sort
of more accurate at the lower case
counts but when we got to these larger
case counts
um maybe then the differential equation
kind of uh style modeling is more
appropriate still with uncertainty
quantification on the top so still with
parameter uncertainty that you have to
think through that that was the new
style of modeling that we looked at and
one thing that was very interesting that
came out of that modeling was that
testing is only
useful in that it reduces quarantine and
isolation
uh if you do it enough if you don't do
it enough then you don't significantly
um cut these infections and there's also
a problem with that if you if you're
testing at a certain rate you are
detecting cases by law we're required to
isolate those cases so there's a kind of
a there's a catch-22 here test enough
you're catching lots of potentially mild
cases that you would otherwise not worry
too much about but that when you catch
those cases you have to quarantine and
isolate so even the asymptomatic cases
right that you wouldn't otherwise find
testing may find those so there was this
very difficult question of how much
should we test if at all going forward
so
one other critical thing was we we we
found that you know we had to predict
like what would happen um as the the
spring semester progressed a big issue
is that when you think about those case
counts that you're seeing in the early
stages of some outbreak
the people that are most likely to be
infected are the more social individuals
those with more contacts
so if you just look at those case counts
that you're seeing in those early days
you're going to overestimate what you're
going to see in case counts through the
rest of the semester and so that was
something that we spend a fair bit of
time trying to uh to model and
understand
so
this modeling led to a new style of
strategy for the spring semester so
basically we wanted to avoid having to
put people into isolation all the time
because it's really tough on them for
learning outcomes and mental health but
we also had to try to balance that with
with health so we did a few things we
extended our move-in period so that
there would be a sort of a more of a
gentle ramp into the semester we relaxed
our regular PCR testing
um we had a few other accommodations
that you would have seen and used in in
your place as well
so
um uh these were all critical things
that came out of the modeling and the
data analysis that then again informed
the university policy
so the key points that I want to
highlight in what I've shown you are
asymptomatic screening super powerful in
controlling outbreaks and making things
safe if you can keep up
uh we did reopen we have been safe till
now but we have had our moments and the
modeling and data analysis was was core
uh we uh I showed you some of the
analysis but there was a lot of other
stuff um You probably have been involved
in similar sort of efforts in your local
areas uh we all the code is available
you can find it um on this GitHub repo
so we also have a paper in proceedings
at the National Academy of Sciences
um
but this is this experience has been
valuable in many ways and a big one is
how it's seeded new research so I'm
going to finish on this slide so
um we now know based on looking back at
this experience that we went through
what tools we wish we had access to in
the moment and so yes uh having a sort
of a suite of models that we can pull
off the shelf and then think carefully
about the parameters for would have been
helpful that would have been great
um but really it was the parameter
uncertainty that was the The Big Driver
of all of these decisions and the
modeling part was was it was it was work
but it wasn't the the core
so the uncertainty quantification how do
you represent your uncertainty about
certain key input parameters and there
are many of them right so you have to be
thinking about uh the sort of
relationships between those parameters
um the second Point uh early infections
are more likely to be the more social
individuals and the issue that's going
on here is if you just count those count
those cases then you're going to
overestimate what's going on in the
general population and if you're a bit
puzzled by this point think about
something called the Friendship Paradox
which says if you look at how many if
you you know if you think about say
Facebook and you think about how many of
your friends how many friends
do your friends have
so you are an individual look at uh the
set of your friends on Facebook
count the average number of friends they
have
and compare that to the average number
of friends you have it will be larger
the reason it's larger is that you're
friends with somebody who was an
incredible socialite and that person has
an enormous number of friends and so
there's a sort of a systematic way that
this this biases things and so we had to
try to reverse reverse that effect
and finally when you are when you do
have these limited interventions for us
that was testing but it could be
vaccination or many others how do you
extend that to multiple groups in such a
way as to curtail growth rates so we're
working on all of these some of them
statistical some of them uh uh more
optimization based with a group of six
of us that are it's a mix of Public
Health and operations folks and a
sociologists so I will stop there thank
you very much for the chance to be here
Shane thank you so much this was your
experience at Cornell was super
interesting and I mean obviously it's it
seemed to have worked for you and you
were successful in kind of allowing
people to come back to campus and to to
have in-person classes which is you know
I think is something everybody wanted
the going online obviously was was
fraught it was sort of necessary but but
fraud and you guys came back and you
were early adopters of coming back to
that I'm curious like what other I'm
sure you've interacted with other
universities
um and other colleges around the country
both more in urban settings as well as
in more rural settings and did they see
some of this
um these effects that were kind of
predicted by your model and can you say
uh you know make some changes to the
parameterization of the model and try
and predict the experiences they might
have had if that makes sense yeah I know
I understand uh the point it's a it's a
great Point um so yes there were other
universities that had similar
experiences so too that appeared in the
news quite a bit were Duke and UIUC so
let me just highlight UIUC I guess so
again a campus that is in a moderate
sized town uh maybe they're quite a bit
bigger than Ithaca I think but um but
nevertheless a campus that sort of
somehow removed from a large urban
center and they they had a similar
strategy and that similar strategy
worked for them we did not explicitly uh
share our models with them in in real
time because they had their own modeling
group that was working on this as well
but certainly the since we've had time
to sort of take a deep breath after all
of this kind of Madness over the last
couple of years we have been working on
cleaning up the code ensuring that that
kind of uncertainty quantification which
was you know that that I think was
really the key in in everything we were
doing that is all available online and
we have not done what you've said which
is to explore their particular setting
without you know sort of adopt adapting
the parameters for those settings but
certainly that would be something that
would be very doable in the work we're
doing right now we're thinking much more
about a broader Community like in a
university community you can control
Behavior you can put into place these
behavioral compacts there are at least
at many universities not all uh but what
about a broader community so when you
get into the more rural areas around
Ithaca you certainly can't do that so
what would be you know what what are the
overall Dynamics there so that's the
thing that we're focusing much more on
in in the present time yeah because I
think it's interesting that University
and college campuses are kind of an
interesting petri dish for
point of phrase here uh it's uh for this
type of a thing and you might imagine
that you know your experience in Cornell
where you know why forget what you
mentioned like 20 000 students uh is
about the the size of the the on you
typical in Residence Community there in
Contra and you know you you're not
necessarily in a major urban center but
you've got a college town around you um
in contrast to something like if you
were at NYU for example so you're like
in the middle of a big metropolis and
students are going to be coming into
contact with all sorts of other
non-students and non-academics they're
going to have just a different EX
exposure probability because they wrote
on a subway with somebody and that's
again in contrast to some other place
like Dartmouth which is up in rural New
Hampshire which got a really teeny town
next to it but it's also you know an Ivy
League school but its experience is
going to be different than that Cornell
and you know University of Washington or
Cal Poly Pomona or you know some other
school I'm just kind of curious about
just how that you know works out because
you're different you know you mentioned
all the the students who are more social
maybe the ones that are bringing the
virus to to campus and um you know if
they're interacting with each other as
well as other people from outside the
university you know maybe that has a a
factor a bearing on some of the
performance of the models it absolutely
does so
um we we were in close contact with Ed
Kaplan at Yale it is a a real star in
our community who's done just a
tremendous amount of different policy
analysis work including very early work
on needle exchange programs for HIV all
the way through so uh Yale um as I'm
sure you know is a is a sort of a
moderate sized campus but in a very
Urban setting and so
it's a it's a very interesting uh case
in point that compares with with ours
and they were also trying to do regular
asymptomatic screening and uh but they
had many more cases so
um I think it's exactly this point that
you're making that the the contacts with
the local community create a new source
of infections which uh we could we could
you know to a large extent avoid we
still have a local community but nothing
like the size of uh New Haven in
Connecticut
I it was touched by your comment about
uh mbas and St Patrick's Day don't go
well with each other and I was surprised
in looking at some of your your graphs
that uh I didn't it didn't quite connect
with me but I didn't realize that
Cornell was such a party school but
oftentimes the biggest predictor of an
outbreak was whether or not it happened
around you know times of Celebration
let's just say and that I'm curious what
was the University's request of the
student body in an attempt to kind of
avoid those things I mean you know it's
college kids they're going to do their
fraternity parties that sort of thing
but did the University specifically ask
them not to do those things and they did
them anyway or what seemed to be the
sociology there yeah it's a very
interesting
um deal so so the university did have a
behavioral compact students had to sign
this compact to say that they were going
to be careful and isolate and do their
best to avoid multiple contacts per day
and yes you still have a modest minority
who are going to engage in riskier
behavior for sure and so we kind of knew
that going and we just didn't know quite
how much of an impact that would have uh
overall our uh delightful surprise was
that the Cornell students as a whole
were were not the Partiers right they
were they were mostly very very
responsible and so you know they really
deserve a tremendous amount of credit
they knew that um their in-person
semester relied on them being careful
because if they weren't everyone was
going to have to be sent home and so
this was something that really uh I
think motivated many of them but we were
still pleasantly surprised at how how
responsible they were nevertheless yeah
you still have those moments um you know
everyone needs to blow off some steam
now and then and I guess uh you know we
had a little bit of bad luck at times
but but you know in some ways I think
that's inevitable and you need this kind
of that's why you need this sort of
buttress against uncertainty so when you
do get those surges can you get the
search under control quickly yeah I I
can certainly understand and uh the the
students needed that opportunity to kind
of you know
all that stress intention was uh was a
lot for everybody so I can't blame them
at all
um what are some of the things moving
forward what are some of the
opportunities that people interested in
data science and statistical modeling
and uh predictive modeling in particular
um what are some of the opportunities
that may exist
um you know now that we're coming out of
kind of that experience not that it's
gone away necessarily but we're kind of
emerging from it still
um but what can we what can we learn
what can we move forward with what are
the opportunities that exist you know I
I think there's some very interesting
things here I mean obviously
mathematical epidemiology is a very old
field with the tremendous depth and
literature which is just fantastic it's
a huge resource for us
um but there I think one thing that has
maybe received a little bit less
attention is this interplay between the
data and analysis and the decision
models that sort of feed on those that
data and and the parameters you can get
from that so there's a there's almost
like there's a group that does the data
analysis and then there's a separate
group that does the decision modeling
and never never shall these two groups
mixed right and and I think that's
that's where there's there's huge uh
opportunity and that's where we're
trying to focus our effort so we want to
take into account this data we want to
analyze it in real time but we also want
to recognize the limitations of that
data when you're contact tracing and you
have a surge you can be overwhelmed and
so that leads to a sort of a a censoring
of data and so you have to think about
that when you're when you're fitting
your parameters and if you ignore it
it's at your peril and all of that feeds
into decision models meanwhile there's a
there's a flow back as well like for a
decision if the decision
um with a with a reasonable set of
parameters is very very clear it's miles
away from a different decision being
optimal as we experienced with coming
back for an in-person semester that
means there's a lot of robustness to
that decision and uh you don't have to
get your parameter estimates very
accurate to know that you're still safe
with that decision and so that means
that you can spend a little bit less
effort
um in in gathering the the you know the
sort of detailed data on the ground for
that so I I do think it's that interplay
which is the the growth area right now
Shane thank you so much for for sharing
your experience from Cornell I think
this is uh super interesting and uh I
was like again very interested to see
the performance of your model that it
impacted the strategies that Cornell
undertook to come back a little earlier
than everybody else I'm very thankful
that a lot of those predictions seem to
have borne out and it's uh I know you
must be very relieved but thank you for
sharing that experience with us and
everybody who's uh joining us or or
watching online
um thank you so much we will not be
having our seminar next week in honor of
uh the Thanksgiving holiday here in the
U.S but uh we look forward to uh seeing
everybody the following week um in early
December and uh once again Shane thank
you so much for sharing your experiences
with us
thank you Jack and thanks everyone for
coming along